Heracleion was once believed to be a myth like Atlantis.
But it's real.
The city disappeared beneath the Mediterranean Sea around 1,200 years ago,...
...and was found during a survey of the Egyptian shore at the beginning of the last decade.
The city was believed to have been a very important place of knowledge, trade, and religion...
...and had even been visited by Helen of Troy.
Scientists have discovered the remains of more than 64 ships, gold coins,...
...giant 16-foot statues and hundreds of smaller statues of minor gods on the sea floor.
The city is submerged under 150 feet of water in the bay of Abu Qir.
It is believed that in the eighth century B.C. when the city was built,...
...it would have sat at the mouth of the river Nile.
Scientists still have little idea what caused the city to sink.
But a number of things could have caused it.
From an earthquake, gradual sea level rise,...
...or sudden collapse of the unstable sediment that the city was built on.
The pictures taken of the statues beneath the water are truly amazing.
And I for one cannot wait to hear about what they find next at Heracleion.